القى رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه سابق عمران
خان باللوم على قائد الجيش السابق الجنرال
قمر جاويد باجو ومتهم اياه بالتامري مع
الولايات المتحده لاسقاط حكماته خنقله
خلال لقاء ان مع صحافيين من وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه في مدينه لاهور انه لم يكن يستطع
الكشف عن دور الجنرال سابقا خشيه التهامه
بالتحريض على القوات المسلحه
على انه اتهام للجيش في المجمل وهو ما
خشيت الوقوع فيه لذا انتظرته حتى تنتهي
ولايه الجنرال باجوا والان فانها سببا
انتقادي له بسيط جدا فليشرح لي اولا ما
سبب تغييره حكومه التي كانت افضل من
سابقاتها ثم لماذا استبدال حكومه بحكومه
نصوص
لهؤلاء اللصوص باعفاء انفسهم من قضايا
فساد بقيمته خمسه مليارات دولار من
المسؤول عن كل ذلك الاجابه هي الجنرال
باجوا